[Musique]
mon compte Instagram c'est en compte
d'éducation à la santé sexuelle mais
aussi au plaisir sexuel qui est tenu
donc par moi-même qui suis infirmière
sexothérapeute l'idée c'est de libérer
la parole autour de la sexualité pour
que ça devienne un sujet comme un autre
et que donc ça devienne moins tabou mon
envie première c'est aussi que les gens
prennent conscience des enjeux de la
sexualité notamment du consentement du
non consentement mais aussi qu'on puisse
un petit peu s'amuser au lit et parce
que l'éducation sexuelle est vraiment
centrée sur la prévention dans les
établissements mais moi j'ai aussi envie
que tout le monde puisse s'épanouir dans
sa sexualité et ça passe aussi par le
plaisir
[Musique]
nous on a envie de réinvestir la
sexualité qui soit pas une sexualité
crue et sans et sans interaction autour
on parle aussi de connexion émotionnelle
de de liens à son propre corps parce que
la sexualité c'est pas que la sexualité
à deux et l'idée c'est vraiment de
remettre ça dans un contexte
bienveillant consentant enthousiaste et
pas dans une sexualité qui soit purement
mécanique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de remettre le consentement
au cœur des interactions mais pas
forcément que dans la sexualité au cœur
de des interactions dans la société et
ça peut être aussi sur des actes par
exemple on éduque aussi au consentement
de ce qui pourrait se passer dans une
séance de gynécologie on a tellement eu
l'habitude que nos corps nous ne nous
appartiennent pas que dans les séances
de consultation gynécologique il y a
très peu de la part des soignants
d'explications sur ce qui va se passer
de demandes de consentement à pratiquer
un acte pénétratif quand même et donc
tout ça voilà nous c'est recentré en
fait le corps l'intégrité du corps
d'avoir une semelle entière où on prend
le temps d'expliquer de former de
montrer le champ des possibles des lieux
où on peut être accueillis où on peut
apprendre où on peut arriver en urgence
etc quand moi c'est c'est hyper
rassurant
[Musique]